foreign
welcome to the show
thank you Rachel and John how are you
we're doing well thanks for calling
what's up Rita
fantastic okay my question is should I
pay off this last day so I've been
working on my budget I'm so proud of
myself thanks for the app that you guys
have we're proud of you too Rita well
done
yeah
I'm crunching all the numbers and after
I pay this debt which is a consumer debt
of 1
320.41 I will have left in my account
um about sixteen sixteen hundred dollars
um
I'll tell you in the beginning of the
year I was I had about six thousand
dollars worth of debt it just piled on I
don't even know how I did it um I was
working at a retail store making about
17 an hour
um but as of last month I was offered a
position making 95 000. oh wow yes doing
what breed is a gangster dude what are
you doing
I'm in insurance and I want to thank you
guys too because I used to be in
Insurance about 12 years ago
um left that to live a little more and
I've been out of insurance about seven
years now and I was listening to one of
the the shows and I don't know what
happened but you guys were just talking
about insurance
umbrellas this and that and I was like
is this a sign
[Laughter]
I reached out to a buddy who I know is
still in the insurance industry I said
Hey listen I'm thinking about coming
back and
okay read it so tell me about this debt
is it handsome
is it just so lovely
like why do you want to why do you want
to why do you want to hang on to it so
tightly it's got it
the main numbers win everything I'm good
you know what I think I answered my own
question right pay it off
are you the first person in your family
to go go down this road
um
no I don't think so I think I'm the only
one who's taking a stand on it that's
what I mean that's what I mean okay so
here here's I can imagine this is just a
psychological thing
you're about to cross a line that was
always in your life for other people
other people didn't owe money other
people
got to sleep all night and not worry
about how their bills were going to get
paid other people and now you're about
to step over a line
that really doesn't exist by the way
but you're going to step over a line
that you're going to become the other
person now
and often we get hung up right before
that that's why weight is so hard to
lose because man oh those people the
skinny people just gets is hard right
and we can fill in the blank oh they
drive those kind of cars
um so you're about to cross the line and
what Rachel and I would tell you is
don't just step over that line Sprint
across it screaming and yelling the
whole way
okay because there is no other people
we're all in this big sinking ship
together so just run across it as fast
as you can cheering all the way okay and
you make 95 Grand your emergency fund
will be built up in what three months
you'll be good to go yes yes I already
have the um the thousand dollars in
there
um
I have a hundred and thirty thousand
right now Rita right now you're trying
to make this a math problem you're free
lady
okay you're free you got it Rita do it
do it today do it today done and then oh
I just cut off I'm so sorry Rita
I bet you I was just gonna talk Rachel's
the hospitable one on the show no uh but
isn't that it is you're free it I'm like
it's right there and it's almost this
intimidation of oh is this real like
it's this yeah what is this and I get
going down to 1600 which we say a
thousand dollars so you're even 600
buffered more than what we even would
say I think she has her thousand bucks I
think when she pays it all she's still
gonna have 1600 bucks in her account
with that yeah yeah yes and so yeah you
got this Rita and and well done on
pursuing a whole new career she's
working retail making 18 an hour and
just thinks oh I could get back to
Insurance how many times do we hear that
when somebody's getting when they cross
the halfway point
of their debt-free Journey they just
start walking taller and demanding like
I don't have to live like this yes and
then also they get promoted get new jobs
making 95 Grand start to see how Rita
you did it Well Done Rita we are
cheering you on sleep well tonight
knowing that it's paid off it's paid off
it's awesome well only free person in
New York that's awesome